all right
it's all psychological
you yell barracuda
everybody says huh what
you yell shark
[Music]
we've got a panic on our hands on the
4th of july
millions of americans are ready to hit
the beach this independence day weekend
and while the chances of a shark
encounter are slim some officials are
taking that possibility more seriously
than the mayor from jaws there meg
oliver has more on what you need to know
before you head back into the water
they got the victim in the ambulance and
got her to the hospital a 17 year old is
recovering from a shark attack along the
florida panhandle she had been in the
water thursday fishing with her family
it's a tragedy that's what's happened
and it looks like she's going to lose
her legs what we've been learning
florida has 60 percent of the nation's
shark attacks warning signs are in
places like cape cod where shark
sightings have temporarily closed some
beaches off the california coast a
swimmer nearly bled to death last week
after a sudden attack at a spot he says
he's waited in twice a week for the past
10 years beachgoers saved his life we
had to quickly cut his wetsuit off of
him and
open it all up and then try to apply the
tourniquets to each limb because he was
bleeding severely for those headed to
the beach there are new apps that track
shark sightings but officials say use
common sense don't dump fish in the
water use fishes bait and all that this
is causing sharks to have a feeding
frenzy oh we swim in a group
avoid water at night and most of all
take the lifeguards instructions
seriously
there were 47 shark bites in 2021 more
than a 40 percent increase from the
previous year but experts still stress
they are extremely rare in fact your
chances of it happening are one in 11
million for cbs saturday morning meg
oliver sandy hook new jersey
they're rare
the chance is not zero right that's
important
i know every time we do the jaws and
we're making light we're not making
light we know the seriousness it's just
it is the first thing you think of is
that movie which terrified most of us to
go into the way that you're going to
need a bigger boat yeah
exactly
who else it